what city is the true comedy capital of
the world right now in your opinion God
I hate you're setting that up as if it's
supposed to be Austin Austin's the
comedy Capital World New York always
will be it's always New York it doesn't
make a difference how good Austin's
doing right now it's a great place but
New York is diverse whereas Austin is
all the same one comic nothing against
him that's the guy the Bro comic works
you know what I mean it's it's I love it
I love dude I think Shane Gil is the
[__] funniest dude in the world and then
there's just a bunch of all shoots of
him Tim Burley what is the true comedy
capital of the United States it's
Philadelphia Pennsylvania and there's no
doubt about it there's no second place
dude everyone keeps saying that I mean
obviously do you have like higher levels
of talent in other places in higher
concentrations yeah but think about all
the [__] whack they pack in with it dude
Philly's just number one you know what
I'm going to just be a [__] and go
Tonto when you talk about comedy Capital
that's a subjective because in Austin
We're 300 it's not a lot of us but all
of us that are there are Mighty but when
it comes to Stage time and most stages
you have to say